ich habe den schlechtesten Club in ganz
Berlin getestet um zu schauen ob es dort
wirklich so schlecht ist wie im Internet
beschrieben denn new West Club sticht
mit super wenigen aber dafür vielen
schlechten Bewertungen heraus Sie
Getränke sein zu teuer und das Ambiente
soll komisch und nicht einladend wirken
außerdem haben meine Berliner Freunde
noch nie von diesem Club gehört und wir
haben uns auf den Weg gemacht
Members Only soll ich mal klopfen
Klingel
da ist doch Musik oder meinte die können
von drinnen da durch gucken aber wir
können halt nicht rein gucken
okay Leute wir sind mittlerweile im Club
bzw donnerstags ist das wohl eine Bar
aber wir sind die einzigen hier obwohl
der Alarm schon mit vier Stunden auf hat
und es ist natürlich alles super dubios
aber der Typ ist nett er hat uns ein
paar Getränke gezaubert die Karte ist
sehr vielfältig aber es gibt halt nicht
alles dann lass was machen oder im Club
s
hey leute es ist jetzt tatsächlich doch
noch ein Lied gekommen jetzt